sport emerged the george kittle and the
49ers are close to a deal and the entire
nfl
media industrial complex rose up to say
it was fake
and phony it ignored it and now here we
are
report from nfl media and others as far
as i know it's been two hours since the
show
started there may be more out there
george kittle and the 49ers
close to a deal so it is something
that's happening and it's something that
needs to happen chris
this is one of the most important
players on that team they need to make
him happy
they need to secure his future and it
looks like they're about to do it yeah
well i'm not shocked i mean you know you
you said all the right things and you
know first off yeah i know kyle shanahan
i know what he thinks of george kittle i
mean kittle's special you could argue
kittle's the best player on their
football team
let alone being one of their best
example setters as far as a leader a
worker
intensity all of those things and then
when you have a guy like shanahan who
his offense is based around the run game
a great tight end is a
great weapon with that is he blocking is
he sneaking out on a play action pass
all of those things so i would expect
him to blow
uh the current tight end contracts out
of the water here
and in a season with likely no fans or
if any few you're gonna need someone to
light the fire every week and we know
how george kittle can fight the fire of
the team he's gonna be a key key player
this year for the 49ers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports